We Begin this hour with Russia's
decision to pull out of the Black Sea
grain deal a decision that will have
Global ramifications the agreement was
due to expire on Monday evening Russia
signed two deals a year ago one that
allowed Ukraine to keep exporting grains
safely the other was with the UN to ease
restrictions on Russian food and
fertilizer exports it's all started our
reports from Istanbul
this is The Last Ship carrying Green
from Ukraine under the Black Sea Green
initiative brokered by the United
Nations and turkey
now Russia has pulled out seeing its
demands have not been met
Russia wants to see an end to Western
impose sanctions on the Russian
agricultural bank and to restrictions on
shipping and insurance that Moscow says
has hampered its agricultural exports
turkia is one of the main beneficiaries
of the deal and it's hopeful it can be
held together
I believe my friend President Putin
wants this humanitarian bridge to
continue in the meantime our foreign
minister will hold his meetings with his
counterpart and I will meet with Mr
Putin as soon as I return from the trip
when we meet with him in our country in
August we will have the opportunity to
discuss all these issues we will also
explore how we can act on Paving the way
for the shipment of Russian grain and
fertilizer
the deal was struck last year amid fears
of Global Food shortages after Russia
invaded Ukraine nearly 33 million tons
of grain and other foods have left
Ukraine under the agreement through a
corridor across the Biloxi that allowed
Ukraine to export its crane safely
without Russia's security guarantees
Ukrainian ships will no longer be able
to sail from its ports
the European Union's High representative
has accused Russia of weaponizing hunger
this is something very serious that will
create a lot of troubles to many people
around the world
we from our side we will do everything
we can through our solidarity Lanes in
order to make available the Ukrainian
grain for the people who eat from it
and have to blame Russia for this
decision completely unjustifying
weaponizing the hung of the people
according to the U.N low-income
countries receive only three percent of
the Ukrainian grain under the deal but
it says the agreement has benefited
people worldwide by putting more food
products onto the global market and
reducing prices since July last year
nearly 33 million tons of grain and
other foods have passed through the
Black Sea nearly half of that has gone
to high income countries in the European
Union turkey has received 10 percent
making it the third largest recipient
now many here hope the good relations
between Ankara and Moscow could still
save the deal
Al Jazeera Istanbul
at the moment we'll have reaction from
Rob McBride in Ukraine but first let's
go to Yulia chapavolova in Moscow so
Yulia we've heard some positive
optimistic signals from Turkish
officials is that being mirrored by
Russian officials
well not really there will be no more
negotiations according to the Russian
mission to the UN at the decision to
withdraw from the grain deal is Final in
a statement released by the Russian
foreign Ministry they also have
confirmed that Russia is withdrawing its
guarantees from this safe
navigation in the Black Sea and
canceling the maritime humanitarian
Corridor in the north western part of
the blank sea so initially Russia
demanded to reconnect its agricultural
bank or Ross Bank in Russian to the
Swift payment system and to resume work
called the toliati Odessa ammonia
pipeline a part of it was later blown up
on the Ukrainian territory and also the
deal was meant to supply food to the
poorest countries but according to
reports who understand that the a larger
share of the Russian Ukrainian food
produce was sent to developed but not
developing countries so in none of those
conditions were met actually and earlier
there were also high hopes that Russia
would would have signed the deal by the
forthcoming Russia Africa forum and it's
just going to take place in Saint
Petersburg at the end of July so many
ask now what President Putin is about to
say to all those African presidents and
leaders and whether they will arrive in
Saint Petersburg after Russia's decision
what are Russian officials saying about
the timing of this decision coming
right after the attack on their Kirch
bridge between Mainland Russia and
occupied Crimea
well they say that Russia was not
willing to extend the deal anyway so
that's according to the authorities but
probably the attacks ruled out all the
possible negotiations uh recently
President Vladimir Putin was holding a
meeting with his ministers And
discussing what needs to be done to
restore the bridge and the latest we've
heard is that one part of the bridge
span closer to the Crimean city of Kirch
will be dismantled as it cannot be
restored and the second part is now
being strengthened by Builders the
railway part of the bridge is working
normally at the moment as we understand
but the cars are now being suspended but
the traffic can be partially resumed by
the end of this of the day that's
according to to the president's
ministers all right we'll leave it there
thanks so much Julia chapalva
McBride joins us now for more on this so
Rob first of all where does this leave
Ukraine's ability to export its grain at
this point
yeah there are bound to be consequences
for Global Food surprise given the
Reliance upon the grain that does come
from Ukraine it remains unclear though
just of how serious these consequences
are going to be and that's because the
picture that we're facing now is very
different to what we were facing a year
ago when this grain deal first came into
being uh obviously there was as a result
of the war massive disruption of grain
shipments out of Ukraine we saw an
instant price hiking uh foodstuffs of
some 30 percent uh fears of famine on
the African continent and so on since
then things have stabilized somewhat in
part because of the corridor because of
the grain deal and we've seen prices
decrease quite a lot but also because of
the shortage especially in recent months
of ships that have been allowed to go
through and Export grain from Ukrainian
ports many farmers food exporters from
Ukraine have found other ways of getting
their crops out of exporting food using
rail links and land borders also ports
on the Danube River so all these
different ways it combined with the fact
that there is now less food for export
as a result of the war about a third
less that uh Ukraine is exporting and
they work with the Ukraine wasn't so
reliant on these uh Black Sea ships
anymore certainly there will still be
consequences but it remains to be seen
just how serious it will be and we are
having remarks from Vladimir zelenski's
office comments carried on social media
about even without Russia's uh help in
this matter with Russia not pull it with
now pulling out of the deal possibly
with turkey A's help of continuing uh
shipments across the Black Sea it's not
known how that will work but uh Vladimir
zielinski said he's been approached by
shippers and also food exporters willing
to keep ships going across the Black Sea
although how this would work out with
insurance
Etc in what is effectively a war zone
Still Remains unclear
and Rob I've got to ask you about the
bridge attack as well so from what we
can make out how much of a setback has
this proved to be to Russian logistical
operations
yeah I don't think you can overestimate
her the impact of this in in terms of
the symbolism of it but also the
Strategic value of the Kirch Bridge it
was built in 2018 as a a victory project
if you like a very personal to vote to
Vladimir Putin it really cemented
Russia's hold uh on Crimea after their
occupation in 2014 and it's one of the a
few land routes that can keep Crimea
supplied we have the the land bridge
from the Don bass going through the
territories seized by Russia we also
have some uh shipping connections and
air air connections but really the this
bridge is extremely important in getting
Munitions fuel uh water uh getting
troops in and out of Crimea and I think
this really now concentrates uh the uh
the the counter offensive with the goal
of Ukraine's goals its stated mission of
reclaiming Crimea it really does show
the vulnerability now as this
counter-attack continues of this whole
peninsula
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much Rob McBride
the U.S ambassador to the U.N Linda
Thomas Greenfield has called Russia's
withdrawal from the Black Sea grain deal
an act of Cruelty
Russia has dealt another blow to the
world's most vulnerable This Time by
suspending its participation in the
Black Sea grain initiative
this is really another Act of Cruelty
according to the world food program more
than
345 million people are suffering from
high levels of food insecurity and we
know without a shadow of doubt
that Russia's brutal war against Ukraine
has pushed millions and millions more
people to the brink especially in the
Middle East and Africa
diplomatic editor James Bays joins us
now live from the United Nations James
been some been some tough words from the
U.N Secretary General as well right
yeah the Secretary General has been
working very very hard on the grain deal
he was one of the key figures in getting
this deal in place nearly a year ago
because this deal has died after just
under a year uh nearly was approaching
its anniversary uh he invested a great
deal of his political capital a great
deal of effort
um in this deal uh he'd even been
writing to President Putin in recent
days with a new proposal also stressing
to the Russians all the things that
Secretary General had done to try and
help gate Russian food and fertilize out
onto International markets I'm told he
got no reply to that last letter to the
Russians and all the UN received was a
terse note saying the deal was
terminated that is the word that was
used in the communications to the UN to
Ukraine and to turkia and so not
surprisingly the Secretary General very
frustrated
ultimately
participation in these agreements is a
choice
but struggling people everywhere and
developing countries don't have a choice
and there is if millions of people face
hunger and consumers are confronting a
global cost of living crisis and they
will pay the price
I've seen actually the note that was
sent to the United Nations uh
terminating this deal as I said that is
the word termination it's only a few
lines long very very terse indeed and
it's also worth adding that I've spoken
to the deputy Russian ambassador to the
United Nations Dimitri poliansky a
couple of hours ago as he was walking
into the security Council I said could
there be more negotiations he said
there'll be no more negotiations I said
is it definitely dead he said it is
final so pretty definitive I think if
you believe uh the Russian mission to
the United Nations the situation right
now there'll be more discussion about
this coming up uh in the next hour
because there is a security council
meeting that was planned anyway on
Ukraine chaired by the British foreign
secretary James cleverley some other
foreign ministers will be around the
security council's horseshoe table
although Russia will be represented only
by its Ambassador at that meeting which
as I say starts in an hour's time all
right thanks so much James Bay is there